[موسيقى]
في هذه المدينه لا حاجه لك لتبحث عن
مبدعيها او تسال عن عناوينهم فهم متوفرون
في كل ناحيه منها تقريبا تركوا ظلالهم
وبصماتهم وحكاياتهم والوانهم واجزاء من
سيرهم وتجاربهم على جدرانها وفي مكتباتها
وحدائقها خاصه
اولئك الذين كانوا اطفالا يوم تاسس موسمها
او مهرجانها السنوي وكبروا معه
حكيم غيلان هو واحد من هؤلاء المبدعين
الذين انجبتهم هذه المدينه اصيله
وتدربوا في محترفها
وورشها السنويه على فن الرسمي والحفر
حكيم غيلان نعم حكيم غيلان انت ابن اصيله
نعم ابن اصيله فكرت باسمك
حكيم والله القصه غريبه شويه الاسم انا في
ابتدائي كنت بكتب حاكم حاكم حاكم بالالف
مثل الحاكم باي الله الخاتمه لما عرفت
من الداخل ما عجبني اسمي
صححوها ولا اي شيء فدائما تاني بالحاكم
العسكري الحاكم بامر الله اشياء مثل هذا
لكن لما طلعت الاعدادي بيحطوا لنا كارت
المدرسه عليه صوره لما صار اسمي حكيم فرحت
كثير عرفت انها من الحكمه التي لازلت ابحث
عنها دائما
[موسيقى]
نحاول دائما ان نكون متحررين في التعبير
او في العمل الفني لكن تكون دائما هناك
فكره هناك انطلاقه هناك سجون هناك اشياء
داخليه تحب ان تخرجها او فكره تحب توصلها
للاخر
الحكمه هناك مقوله اعجبتني وفي اطار
اللوحات الحروفيات هي حرف الباء الحكمه
يقول احد الحكماء كل الحكمه جمعت في كتاب
الا وهو القران الكريم وكل حكمه الكتاب
القران الحكيم جمعت في الصوره الاولى
الفاتحه
والفاتحه كل حكمتها جمعت في الايه الاولى
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وكل الحكمه الايه جمعت في الكلمه الاولى
باسمي
وكل الحكمه جمعت في الحرف الاول في الباء
فالحكمه موجوده في نقطه الباء في الحكمه
نقطه والجاهل من يتجاهله
هذا الحرف الباء اللي حكيت عليه من قبل
وهادئه نوع من الكتابه المتواجده في
المخطوطات الوالد واي حرف
الاصل ديال الحروف الجميل اللغات هو
العمود والقوس
ترتيب بين العام والقوس كل اللغات كل
الحروف
ودائما دائما شغلك يعني ياتي بهالمعنى من
فكره او من نص معين من جمله معينه من اغلب
الاحيان اغلب الاحيان العفويه عندي لازم
تكون يعني
محدده يعني
مراقبه تماما يعني تتحكم فيها نوعا نوعا
حرف الباء والباب
الباب السهوتني دائما الابواب وخاصه ابواب
المدن القديمه
المتاكله المتلاشيه
يستهوني فيها الماده التي تخلقها الاراده
واكلت السوسه
الصباغه المتراكمه عليها والمتناطره تعطيك
دائما بعد للزمن وتعطيك سفر عبر الازمنه
[موسيقى]
والباب ايضا كما ذكرت هو
خلفه خلفه في حكايات وفي اسرار نقول
في المثل العربي البيوت واسرار
واسرارها كاتبها باب الدار
حكيم انت ابن هذه المدينه اصيله نعم
تظن انك محظوظ ان ولدت في هذا المكان
اكيد
اكيد من الحظ ان هو كل انسان يعشق مكان
ولادته
ولو خيروني ان اختار مدينه غير اصيله
لاخترت اصيله
شو السر انه يعني اذا بنقول محظوظ
لكونه اول امرين اظن الامر الاول انه مكان
الولاده هذا هذا الفردوس دائما يعني
للطفوله الامر الاخر هو انت يعني وعيت او
على مدينه تتكون ابداعيا وفنيا يعني خلقت
واوعيه على بدايات الموسم موسم قصير اللي
ختم عامل اربعين اصيله الحب الذي يكمل لها
انها مدينه صغيره فنحن عائله كبيره الكل
يعرف البعض
قصيده من حظها ايضا انها لها استاذه امينه
اسينسيو الاستاذه التي علمت الاجيال
بالمدرسه الاعدادي فنون الرسم وتاريخ الفن
كذلك اصيله محظوظه ان لها منتدى مثل منتدى
اصيله جمع من فنانين فكانت فصابه اصيله
قبلتا للفنانين والمبدعين تعلمنا الكثير
على ايدي فنانين كبار من المكسيك من فرنسا
من اسبانيا من الدول العربيه الاخرى
لانه لابد انه هذا هذا الموسم السنوي مئات
او الاف الناس يعني عبروا واقاموا في هذه
المدينه في بيوته بالاول ثم في
بحد ذاته كانوا معلمين عابرين هي في كل في
كل ملتقى في كل سنه دائما تخرج بافكار
جديده بتقنيات جديده بالتعرف على اصدقاء
جدد وبتعرف جوانب خفيه من العالم الفن
والابداع طبعا مثل ما قلنا هذا المحج او
هذا الموسم سنه خاصه عبر الورش التي تقام
والجداريات اللي بدنا نحكي عنها طبعا اللي
هي اللي بتميز ايضا احد ميزات هذه المدينه
هو الرسم على الجدران
وهذه الورش الدائمه على مدار شهر تقريبا
كل سنه كل سنه كل سنه اضافه اشياء اخرى
اذا بدنا نتحدث عن الافادات من هذه
التجربه انت بدات بالرسم منذ الصغر نعم
كان عمرك يمكن خمس ست سنوات
اشتغلت في مطبخ المنزل على انه مرسم حتى
لا اكون معاقه من طرف الوادي
الوالد كان خطيب وامام ومعلم ومحتسب يعني
كان جامع كلي وناظر الشرفاء الغيلانيين
بمدينه اصيله
كاي طفل كنتم مهووسا باللعب بالالوان
وتستهون الخربشات على الحيطان القديمه
بالمدينه العتيقه
فكنت احاول تقليدها وتقليد الاشياء التي
اراها عن طريق الالوان وقلم الرصاص
والاوراق البسيطه يعني ما فيش اوراق الرسم
من النوع الجيد اي ورقه كانت يمكن
استغلالها حتى غلاف قالب السكر كان يشتغل
يعني كويس ومين انتبه لها الموهبه من
المحيط من الاهل او من غير الاهل والله
يعني هناك هناك الاخ الاكبر يعني بيرسم
هناك الاخ
محسن بيشتغل على الكتابه والترجمه له مؤلف
الروايه هناك اخ منصف وهو الاقرب الي في
الترتيب يعني العائلي موسيقار وبيشتغل على
طبعا
والوالد كان راضي عن عن توجهك
الوالد في البدايه يعني كان عنده
مش اللي انا باش لاخي الاكبر يعني حتى انه
كان باغي يعمل مدرسه الفنون الجميله وكانت
تعرض من طرف الوارد الرسم حرام واشياء من
هذا القبيل لكن من حظي لما جيت انا كان
الوالد صار اكثر انفتاحا فلما
نوعا ما محلل لكن سكوته
معلم انه رسام ماهر ايوه كان المشتغل
كمعلم فيحكوا لي التلاميذ درسوا عنده ان
كان لما يرسم بقره يعني
والان يوجد عندنا في المنزل الاخ الاكبر
مخدات اثنين رسم الوالد وترجم من اليد
الوالده الله يرحمهما
يعني لوحه فنيه رائعه
[موسيقى]
علاقتي بالوالد والكتب المتواجده بالبيت
كانت تقريبا كلها مخطوطات
وعندنا بالبيت مصحف
خط جدي يعني بخط جميل لانه جدي كان عدل
ووالدي كان عدل كذلك فالدار دائما
[موسيقى]
منذ الصغر العلاقه الخط بالوثائق القديمه
باشياء كبيره لا تمسها لا تلعب بها
فصارت عندي الشيء المحظور يعني مرغوب فصار
لي لابد اخذ اسرق منها بعض الاشياء والان
سرقتها كامله
وحطيتها عليه حتى لوحات هناك لوحات حفر
اشتغلت على مخطوطات يدويه قديمه
سنه 88
محطه الحفر ومحطه اساسيه بتجربتك انت اكيد
هي كل حياتي الفنيه لان تعرفت على الخط في
سنه 1980 على يد استاذ محمد عمر خليل
بمرسم الحفر هنا بالمنتدى وبعدين تطورت مع
اساتذه اخرين مع
فرنسا بالمكسيك من اسبانيا عدد من
الفنانين يعني كل سنه تشتغل وتاخد تقنيات
جديده فصار الحفر عندي مثل المختبر اصيد
وتجربه الوان وورق وهذا نوع فلاني الى
المختبر
واللحظات التي اكون في انجاز اللوحه الحفر
واجراء التجارب الالوان هي اللحظات ممتعه
واهم شيء ان اللوحه رقم واحد قديما في
مجموعته حتى الاخرى لو اهديت او بيعت يعني
ما كيبقاش فيك الحال
محتفظ بكل بكل تقريبا كلهم
[موسيقى]
يمكن القول ان هذه المدينه الصغيره اصيله
هي البيت والمدرسه والجامعه في ان بالنسبه
لاطفالها واجيالها الذين في كل سنه تقريبا
يحصلون على مرتبه جديده في المعرفه من
خلال منتداها الثقافي الفكري والفني
وبالتالي يتعرفون على مبدعين جدد من خلال
الورش التي ينتسبون اليها سنويا ويشرف
عليها كبار الفنانين
والمبدعين من انحاء العالم
ولحكيم غيلان في هذه المدينه الحصه الكبرى
لكونه بدا خطواته الاولى في الحياه وفي
الرسم مع بدايه موسمها الذي اشرف على نصف
قرن من الزمان
انك تكون في مدينه اصيله وتتعرف على
فنانين كثير وتعرف يعني كل مره يكون عندك
مثال تقتدي به
حقيقه ان كثير من الفنانين اثروا في
اعمالي
وكافحت كثير عشان باش نخرج من هذا
وحاول بصمه الخاصه في لوحاته هناك محمد
عمر خليل السوداني في فن ايوه في نيويورك
هناك
طبعا كبار الرسامين مثل
بيكاسو
دائما كنا نحاول
نقلدهم نكون
وقلت لي عملت جهد حتى تبرات يعني تخرج من
خرجت والله ما اقدر احكم على هذا يعني هذا
من صالح الجمهور والمتلقي المتذوق الفني
يحكي
كتير انت اكيد اكيد حتى فادي وكنا بنشتغل
كل سنه يعني حتى بالاشياء القليله اللي
شفتها اليوم
اكيد
انت لاحقا
حاولت يعني تذهب الى التخصص يعني او تتعلم
الرسم
وشو اكتشف التسريات رحت على معادها
الحكايه هذه لما كنت في البدايه في اوائل
الثمانينات وكنت اقوم بمعارض جماعيه مع
الشباب في سني فكان دائما يشوفوا اعمال
بهرو بها ويطرحوا عليا سؤال درست المدرسه
الفنون اقول لا واحس بعقده نقص بعدين لما
وصلت الى البكالوريا عملت اتجاه المدرسه
الفنون الجميله بس لما درست بها واخذت
نفسي انها يعني كنت احسن من قبل من
المدرسه
اللي ضحكت على نفسي بس المدرسه حقيقه تعلم
سعر الكتير
دروس التاريخ الفن كانت اقوى
والرسم الاكاديمي يعطيك يفتح لك ابواب
كثيره حتى اننا تعلمنا ان حتى اللوحات
التجريديه اذا لم تكن القاعده قويه بالرسم
كلاسيكي حقيقه يعني ما تكون تكون فارغه
غير معبره وغير ذات المستوى
دائما كان فيها مزيج من التجريد والواقعيه
نعم اذا اخدنا مثال خربشات على بياض
بالازرق ما يتقبلها لكن اذا حطيت صوره او
رسمت نافذه او جزء صغير من النافذه
يتقبلها يعرف ان هذه خربشه تعني حائط
قديمه الى اخره بس اذا حطيتها لوحدها
لحالها ما ياخذها المتلقي فاذا لهذا كنت
دائما امزج بين الاثنين عشان
راحت المتلقي يعني انت تهجز بالمشاهد اللي
بدو يشوف اللوحه بتفكر فيه كمان يعني تمام
لما تكون تعمل المعرض رسم او عشان الاخر
يشوفوا لو متلقي بتفكر فيه طبعا كجزء مش
عايزه اصدم وعايز ابلغ رساله عايز اعطي
مساج يكون واضح
اصيله تتميزت بتجربه الجداريات وانت كنت
من 13 سنه وقت اللي اظن شارك نعم بموسمها
الاول يمكن نحن نطلق علينا 16 شاب العين
يطلق ما يطلق علينا اليوم باطفال الموسم
نعم منهم حاتم البطيوي عادل عثمان
منهم من معاد الجباري منهم من سار فنانا
ومشى في الميدان ومنهم من بظروف صاروا
صحفيين واشياء اخرى
[موسيقى]
وضحت او كشفت سر اللوحه لان لما تروح
للمعرض وتشوف لوحه جاهزه بالبرواز
والانسان يشوف اللوحه واو عجيبه بس لما
الجداريه تقعد امل فنان وهو بيرسم
تخطيط بفحم الوان اوليه الوان اخيره
بعدين يدخل في ديتاي الجداريات في اصيله
كانت مدرسه مفتوحه للشباب والمهتمين كيف
يرسمون لوحه
[موسيقى]
بدون شك هذه التجربه في الرسم على جدران
المدينه
والورش التي تقام والتي يشارك فيها سنويا
الاطفال
والنشاطات الموازيه من ندوات ومعارض
ومؤتمرات وامسيات شعريه وموسيقيه
تؤسس لانسان مختلف ولذائقه فنيه عاليه
ولها علاقه صحيه وجماليه بالمكان
باعتبارهم امتدادا للبيت وللموسم في ان
واحد وهو الفضاء الذي ينبغي الحفاظ عليه
والاعتناء به وبالتالي تاسس للخيرات لدى
الاجيال لها علاقه بعالم المعرفه والفن
والابداع بعيدا عن التطرف والعنف
حكيم غيلان كما سلف الذكر واكب هذه
التجربه تجربه اصيله منذ انطلاقاتها
الاولى لذا كانت تجربته متاثره بكل
المبدعين الذين عبروها وشاركوا في
محترفاتها وبالتالي كون رؤيا وقراءه عن
مدينته
وموقعها ودورها ولكن من جهه اخرى هل يوجد
مكان للملل لدى الفنان الذي اقترن اسمه
باسم مدينته او نوع من التاطير
هنا يجب ان تكون الحيله ان تعرف تهرب من
الملل الى ان تغير في نفس المكان تغير
النظره اذا كنت تنظر من البحر من النافذه
فحاول ان تنظر اليه من السطح فهمتيني او
في وقت احيانا سكر النافذه والباب واسمع
لي صوت وبس
حتى الرسم يعني تم الفنان يكون بيشتغل
بتقنيه لمده طويله يحس بالماء عشان
يرتاحوا ما يوقف سلسله الابداع يروح على
صباغه على حفر على نحت يغير في الاشياء
بس نعرف انه انت صوتك جميل
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
من الهواه والملوعين بالطرب الاندلسي او
يسمى هنا في المغرب بالطلب الاله
بعمل كورال مع مجموعه من
الجمعيه حسسنا مؤخرا جمعي الاصيليه لعشاق
الاندلسي وكان للشرف انني اكون رئيسها
وبقوم نقوم ببعض التداريب نغني شوي يعني
المديح والسمع بمدينه اصيله
الغناء بدون شك الغناء يعني بيفتح مكان
اخر في الوجدان وفي
فتح لك شيء اضاف شيء على كونك رسام
وتشكيلي فنان
اكيد اكيد لانها لما تكون بتشتغل وتستمع
للموسيقى
هناك اشياء
لاجل الكلمات لشرحها لانها تشتغل تفاعلات
الداخليه
الطلب الاندلسي الاشعار جميله جدا
وتفتح المخيله للفنان كذلك
روحاني كتير
روحانيات فيه الطبيعه فيه الخمريات فيه
الصوفي في كل شيء
مكتبه الوالد استفدت منها خارج اطار انه
كونها مخطوطه حضرت الان بلوحتك كنت تقرا
كان عندي اطلاع ديني اكثر
[موسيقى]
يعني في اشي بتحب ترسمها طبعا بتهرب منها
والله والله احيانا بتكون بتشتغل وبتعمل
شيء وبعدين ترجع يعني رسمت اجساد عاريه في
المدرسه فقط
في الدراسه
بموضوع المراه كان بالموازات يشتغل معالج
اجباري على المراه نفس الشيء لكن هو بنفسه
قال اليوم احنا وحكيم نشتغل على نفس
الموضوع بس حكيم بيغطيها وانا بعريها
من غير راس في التعبير في اللوحاته وانا
كنت دائما اشتغل على المراه بالحايك
باللباس الخارجي للمراه المغربيه وخاصه
هذه الظاهره تقريبا الان بقى مراه واحده
تلبس الحايك في اصيله وكان يستهويني دائما
انا فتحت عيني على الوالده الله يرحمها
جدتي تعمل الحايك وفي يعني جماليه كثير في
خلف سر في خلفه سر
ويعطي جماليه للجسد والله جمال الجسد
غريبه
خلاصه القول ان حكيم غيلان علمته اصيله ان
يرسم فرسمها من زوايا رؤيته الخاصه وحفرها
كما يحفر الزمن على جدرانها مروره المهيب
احب مدينته فمدته بكل ما فيها وفتحت له
ابواب سرها وزرقتها وازياء نسائها
ومخطوطاتها في مكتبه الجد والوالد التي
حولها الى جداريات كذلك يمكن القول ان
سيره هذا الفنان هي سيره مدينته
[موسيقى]